much of what we know about durian comes
from those Hurricane Hunters who track
storms from the sky Errol Barnett was
aboard a US Air Force plane that flew
right into the eye of the hurricane he's
now at Keesler Air Force Base in Biloxi
Mississippi
Errol better you than me it sounds like
a dangerous mission good morning well
Toni it sounds dangerous because it is
the aircraft that went into Dorian
before us had to return to base because
of a mechanical issue but let me show
you what we're dealing with here that
military folks will recognize these
aircraft as Hercules c-130s but they've
been modified they're wc-130 js
so that they can take on hurricanes one
of the modifications this external fuel
tank it's one of two and it allows the
aircraft to stay in the air for up to 14
hours making for one truly epic flight
as the 53rd weather reconnaissance
squadron begins their ascent the
menacing target of their mission
hurricane Dorian threatens 25 million
people in its projected path about
10,000 feet in the sky chief pilot
Lieutenant Colonel Jeff Ragusa and his
crew are collecting data to track the
storms impact around the clock helping
people in Florida and Georgia
information that they need to know the
crew drops GPS sensors like these while
flying directly through the Hurricanes I
to its edge and back again as many as
four times they gather information about
the storms speed direction and winds if
you take a look at this radar behind me
you can see that we are in the eye wall
of Hurricane Dorian and you can feel the
turbulence increase the light is
diminishing and it really gives you a
sense for just how unstable the middle
of these massive storms can be up here
the scenery can change within moments
from the gray and choppy eye wall to the
storms eerily bright and serene eye on
the ground violent and dangerous winds
are ravaging the Bahamas
Dorian's next target the United States
and as we left the Bahamas we caught
sight of this sunset over Florida a
reminder that even nature's beauty can
portray approaching danger and one of
those dangers includes thunderstorms and
lightning take a look at this video shot
onboard one of these hurricane hunter
planes on Sunday the cockpit lit up with
this bright purple light because of
thunderstorms taking place around it
these are the only aircraft in the world
permitted to fly through storms like
this there are 12 of them most other
aircraft have to stay 10 to 20 miles
away a Maria Elena this is the next
aircraft to head toward hurricane durian
it takes off here at noon local time
amazing Errol thank you very much